here is charlie kirk seen as a hero to  young conservatives around the country  and all this different stuff  he says well  if trump was raided  then they should raid black lives matter  planned parenthood  and george soros  why would you raid those things that  doesn't make any sense charlie well  let's see if he explains it  and i'm going to say this plainly and  bluntly raids must be met with raids  they raid donald trump's home well why  don't you go raid blm for burning down a  billion dollars with a property in the  summer of 2020. so  each of those property crimes  is being and has been investigated  and  you don't  need a raid  if you don't believe that there is  evidence of a crime  at a location like sometimes you would  just arrest somebody you know you don't  necessarily always need a raid in lots  of types of alleged crimes